so in 2002 Dwayne The Rock Johnson goes  on Howard Stern's show and is shy and is  nervous and is awkward Howard Stern  later says that that was the worst guest  Dwayne The Rock Johnson was the single  worst guest he's ever had on his show he  tells Dwayne as Dwayne who's going to go  to Dwayne Johnson movie I mean honestly  and to think of where he's come from and  where he's gone since then  that at the beginning you might be shy  you might be awkward you might have  people who are experts in the industry  telling you that you can't make it that  you were the worst guest on their show  of all time and it's never going to  happen to you  and if you keep going  and you keep building and you keep  hustling and you keep creating great  things can happen for you too